I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- My wife was in the
hospital with our new baby.
She had just given
birth and I was alone
with my other two children,
who are, FYI, just for the
record, (beeping) nightmares.
My mother-in-law was annoying
me with her text messages.
"Do my dog's eyes
look okay to you?
"How are the windows
in the apartment?
"Clean?
"Was it diarrhea from the dogs?"
What the (beeps) man?
Like, now I gotta go
look at these like
two Pomeranian's dog (bleep).
So, I texted my wife and said,
"Your mother is
annoying me so bad
"I'm going to throw
her in front of a bus."
I looked down and saw
that I had sent that
to my mother-in-law.
(record scratching)
So I like freaked
out and panicked.
I realized that
what I needed to do
was that I texted my
mother-in-law and said,
"Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
"That text was meant
for my cousin Ben,
"whose mother, my aunt Beth,
"is annoying the
(bleep) out of me."
She wrote back like,
"Ha ha."
So I was like, I don't
know if I'm in the clear.
So an hour later,
I texted her again,
"Dude, tell your
mother to lay off."
And you see, I put
the dude in there.
So she wrote back,
"Ha ha ha, still not Ben."
I was like, (clapping)
I did it, I convinced you.
She won't find out
unless she sees this Unsend
thing online or whatever,
but she can't even
really work her computer.
Protip, erase your
text conversations
after they're done.
There's no reason to keep a log
of who you've been
talking to all day.
That's,
Unsend.